merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur serge letchimy merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur de plus plusieurs mois que
vous êtes ministre que la doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre
les conditions d'usagé de certain nombre
d'équipements la possibilité pour la
presse d'exercer son métier
votre capacité à assurer la sécurité des
biens des personnes et de garantir le
droit fondamental à manifester comme les
instructions données par votre ministère
à l'occasion des manifestations qui ne
cesse des miles pays ont été non
seulement interrogés mais contestées je
voudrais avant toute chose salué
l'engagement sans faille de nos forces
de l'ordre police et gendarmerie qui
exercent pour l'immense majorité d'entre
eux leur mission dans le respect des
principes républicains
il ne reste pas moins que depuis le
début de votre prise de fonction des
incidents les accidents les
comportements manifestement contraire à
la déontologie ont été nombreux le
nombre de blessés parfois très
grièvement depuis que vous êtes aux
responsabilités considérables et à tout
dire inquiétant
des enquêtes ont été ouvertes des
procédures judiciaires sont en cause
c'est bien le moins et c'est désormais
la sphère de la justice nous avons
entendu enfin depuis la semaine dernière
des appels à l'éthique des rappel à la
déontologie
c'est l'honneur de la police qui est en
jeu ainsi que l'a rappelé le président
de la république mais ce qui est
l'honneur de la république monsieur le
ministre c'est lorsque la hiérarchie
prend sa part de responsabilité on ne
peut pas être chef que par beau temps
pour le meilleur et jamais pour le pire
la république ne peut se contenter
d'enflure du ton et d'effets de manche
la président le président de la
république refusait au moment de la
sphère benalla la république des
fusibles
il a instauré la république son fusible
la république des lampistes une
république arrogante
lorsque tous les corps intermédiaires
sont discrédités c'est la résilience la
nation qui se trouve fragilisée
l'honneur de la police est aussi dans la
capacité de son chef à assumer ses
responsabilités notamment sa
responsabilité politique monsieur le
ministre vous nous dire avec le bilan
aussi calamiteux comment vous entendez
assumer vos responsabilités ou deux
nous avons le gouvernement envisage d
merci monsieur ai promis quoi la parole
est à monsieur christophe castaner
ministre de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs le
député monsieur le député je crois que
vous n'êtes pas un nouveau parlementaire
ici et vous avez vous même appartenu à
des majorités et à des majorités ou un
monsieur le député on apprend on apprend
la modestie des situations et on apprend
à gérer le temps pensé que des
difficultés d'ordre public ce rennais de
ce gouvernement serait peut-être un tout
petit peu exagéré
alors on peut choisir de faire des
procès politiques on peut choisir de
dénoncer ce que je sais monsieur le
député c'est que l'année dernière nous
avons connu 53000 manifestations dans ce
pays
est ce que je sais c'est que dès le 17
novembre le premier ordre que j'ai donné
comme ministre de l'intérieur c'est
celui d'envoyer policiers et gendarmes
partout notamment sur les ronds points
pour sécuriser les manifestations
monsieur le député la question de
l'éthique n'est pas nouvelle au sein de
la police elle est posée depuis
longtemps et elle est portée et assumée
depuis longtemps par la police nationale
et par la gendarmerie elle est au coeur
au coeur même de leur engagement
parce que la police la gendarmerie le
ministère de l'intérieur sait
parfaitement que nous ne sommes pas dans
des manifestations dont des violences
urbaines dans des émeutes que toutes les
majorités ont connu n'est pas nécessaire
de le rappeler ici dans un combat entre
deux bandes
nous sommes confrontés à des violences
et la police la gendarmerie sont les
seuls légitimes à utiliser la force mais
le corollaire de cette légitimité là
c'est l'exemplarité c'est la
proportionnalité et c'est effectivement
la déontologie qui est le coeur même de
l'information et de l'engagement de nos
forces sécurité intérieure et je
voudrais que les choses soient claires
ici il peut y avoir des erreurs il peut
y avoir des fautes elles font l'objet
d'une instruction le plus souvent
judiciaire et dans tous les cas de
ministres hâtives et elles feront et
elles font l'objet de sanctions
il en va effectivement de l'honneur de
la police de faire en sorte que nous
puissions garantir cette éthique et
faire en sorte qu'elles vivent au
quotidien c'est cela monsieur le député
la réalité de l'engagement de nos forces
de sécurité intérieure
ne les arts et culture est pas mais